bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans sens public votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débats de reportage et de
chronique sur public Scéna 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos invités experts et voici le
sommaire de ce 16 novembre où va le
parti LR son chef erriic soioti a choisi
de snober les rencontres de Saint-Denis
demain elles porteront pourtant
notamment sur l'élarg du champ du
référendum aux questions migratoires les
LR qui sont en plein bras de fer entre
députés et sénateurs sur le contenu de
la loi immigration qui donne le cap que
risqu les républicains en cas d'échec
aux élections européennes dans moins de
7 mois on en débat juste après ces
titres et puis dans 3 quart d'heure
direction l'Ukraine passer au second
plan de l'intérêt médiatique et
politique depuis les attaques du ramas
contre Israël le 7
octobre la guerre au Moyen-Orient
détourne
l'attention je pense que c'est l'un des
objectifs de la Fédération de Russie
elle a compris que lation se porterait
moins sur
l'raine depuis quelques jours l'armée
ukrainienne a posé le pied sur la rive
du fleuve de nipre qui était jusqu'ici
contrôlé par la Russie est-ce le
démarrage d'une percée d'envergure la
contreoffensive peut-elle tir de
l'impasse l'aide internationale a-t-elle
atteint son maximum on répondra à toutes
ces questions tout à l'heure mais
d'abord ces doutes qui s'exprime de plus
en plus sur la stratégie d'éic cioti
Cécile Siou Emmanuel Macron risque de se
sentir bien seul vendredi à Saint-Denis
après manuel bonpard de LFI Olivier fort
des socialistes éic cioti aussi
boycotter à sa réunion le patron DLR n'a
pas apprécié l'absence du chef de l'État
à la marche contre l'antisémitisme il
refuse surtout dit-il de cautionner une
énième opération de communication moi
j'ai pas vocation à être le figurant
d'un spot publicitaire du président de
la République parce que saint n j'ai
participé une fois c'est de la com alors
bien sûr c'est que que de la une
nouvelle défection et un coup dur pour
Emmanuel Macron à l'initiative de ses
rencontre hier à Lausanne il n'a pas
caché son agacement utiliser le que nous
vivons pour justifier une absence à une
réunion de travail sur des réformes
constitutionnelles est absolument
indigne je pense que c'est une faute
politique majeure de la part de ces
dirigeants le chef de l'État avait
pourtant pris soin de mettre sur la
table les réformes constitutionnelles
demandées par l'lr les républicains ont
souhaité qu'il y ait un référendum
autour de la Constitution et autour le
président le met sur la table met sur la
table voilà je le mets sur la table on
pourra en discuter et Monsieur qui l'a
demandé qui dépose une PPL sur le
sujet qui dépose sur le texte loi dit S
fais pas parce qu'il était pas la manif
mais vous rendez compte cette réaction
chez lesr aussi ce refus d'invitation
est diversement apprécié Gérard Larcher
favorable à une relation constructive
avec l'exécutif sera lui présent à
Saint-Denis il se désolidarise à
demi-mot derric c'est sa décision je
peux en comprendre les raisons il est
dans son rôle de président de parti de
prendre cette décision elle lui
appartient cette absence du patron DLR
autour de la table risque en tout cas de
laisser un couloir de nage à une autre
droite celle du rassemblement
national le parti LR est-il devenu un
bateau ivre peut-il disparaître en cas
d'échec aux élections européennes dans
moins de 7 mois on répond à ces
questions en en débat avec Franck Morel
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes avocat
associé chez flichi Granger ancien
conseiller social d'Édouard Philippe
amatignon et de plusieurs ministres et
expert également à l'Institut Montaigne
Bruno quotre bonsoir et bienvenue
politologue chercheur au CNRS et au
cvipov j'accueille également Stéphane
zumsteek bonsoir et bienvenue bonsoir le
directeur du département Opinion chez
hipsos l'institut de sondage hipsos et
Mathilde Sirot bonsoir Mathilde de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau
éditorialiste politique on commence par
cette décision donc d'IC soti de de
snober les rencontres de Saint-Denis
alors effectivement le Parti socialiste
et les fill n'y vont pas non plus euh
Franck Morel mais on est pas exactement
dans le même contexte politique est-ce
que c'est une erreur stratégique ou une
faute pour reprendre les termes du
président de la République la réponse
est dans la question sur l'erreur
stratégique je le crains si j'étais un
peu taquin je dirais que LR qui critique
le en même temps fait lui-même sans
cesse du en même temps et est sans cesse
tiraillé par une forme de en même temps
un peu mortifère pourquoi parce que LR
n'a pas réussi à trancher des
définitivement et c'est ce qui plombe un
peu le décryptage des attitudes et des
postures qui sont retenues sur les
différents sujets entre une posture qui
consisterait à soutenir même de manière
critique le gouvernement ou à être dans
une opposition classique voilà et on l'a
vu au moment de la réforme des retraites
à travers effectivement les tiraillement
qui ont pu être constatés au sein du
groupe LR on le voit en ce moment avec
le vote du projet de loi sur
l'immigration entre le Sénat d'un côté
et
l'Assemblée et du reste ça n'est pas
neutre de mon point de vue le fait que
la position d'Eric cotti qu'il vient
d'affirmer arrive précisément à ce
moment-là juste après le vote par le
Sénat du projet de loi immigration si
vous voulez il y a une logique un peu de
balancier un coup d'un côté un coup de
l'autre on a trop on a trop construit
avec le gouvernement au Sénat donc il
fauton monre voilà donc on fait vivre ce
ce en même temps du coup d'une certaine
manière accord défendant évid parce que
c'est pas en même temps assumé et
revendiqué c'est un en même temps un peu
subi plus exactement mais voilà c'est
c'est ce balancier est revenu du fait
sans doute précisément du vote au Sénat
du texte immigration alors Bruno cot
c'est c'est évidemment une mauvaise
nouvelle pour Emmanuel Macron puisque
cette initiative politique des
rencontres de Saint-Denis bon bah elle
se elle est en train de faire pit on
pourrait dire ça comme ça et est-ce que
c'est forcément à cont une bonne
nouvelle pour le parti LR ce qui est en
train de se passer pour le parti
il y a des dimensions stratégiques en
fait qui expliquent aussi pas mal la
situation au Sénat ils ont au fond jouer
le jeu de au fond prendre le texte du
Gouvernement comme une base intéressante
qu'ils ont durci évidemment tout ceci
nous dit que la confiance n'est pas
optimale sur la capacité de l'exécutif à
accompagner cette démarche jusqu'au bout
et sans doute la crainte chez les
républicains de paraître aux yeux de
leurs électeurs qui restent
encore reste quand même quelques uns
encore leurs sympathisants leurs
militants ceux qui au bout du compte se
feraient avoir c'est-à-dire que ils
auraient joué le jeu et puis le texte
repassé à l'Assemblée nationale
reviendrait sans tout un tas de
d'engagements qui ont été pris au Sénat
dans ce que vous nous dites là en en
préambu c'est c'est une façon aussi de
mettre la pression sur le gouvernement
dans les négociations qui vont qui vont
qui vont avoir lieu là l'assembl savent
qu'ils sont dans une situation
extrêmement paradoxale ce parti n'a
jamais été aussi faible qu'aujourd'hui
et en même temps il se retrouve avec une
position d'acteur stratégique qui peut
donner à Emmanuel Macron une majorité ou
qui peut l'aider à montrer que
finalement l'exécutif n'est pas autant
isolé qu'on le dit donc c'est vrai que
c'est une situation paradoxale il faut
un peu monter les enchères alors il l'a
déjà fait au moment de la réforme des
des des retraites c'est vrai alors ça ça
seppelle jouer aussi un peu avec le feu
ou parce qu'au bout d'un moment les
sympathisants les électeurs ont besoin
qu' une ligne qui s'affirme qui se
clarifie de savoir un peu où ils en sont
c'est pour pour ça qu'on posa la
question du CAP ou ou du bateau boycotte
qui ne fait pas on l'a bien compris
l'unanimité au sein de LR on écoute le
vice-président de la commission des lois
le sénateur LR du Nord Marc Philippe
d'bress nous on sort de la loi sur
l'immigration où on a fait voter un
texte qui à 98 % est-ce que monsieur
sooti a déposé à l'Assemblée nationale
en même temps on va aller vers ce débat
à l'Assemblée nationale au moment où on
cherche justement à imposer une ligne
plus ferme sur ces sujetsl je pense
qu'il vaut mieux continuer à être
présent au discussions avec le président
de la République quitte à lui dire ceci
n'empêche pas cela toutes les
divergences et les différences qu'on a
avec lui c'est donc une erreur d'Éric
suti je ne dis pas ça moi à sa place
j'aurais pas fait pareil voilà en terme
choisi on on sous-entend que c'est quand
même une une erreur Stéphan zumste cette
politique de la chaise vide à qui elle
profite est-ce qu'elle profite au
rassemblement national qui va pouvoir
demain continuer d'afficher sa capacité
à participer à des rencontres comme
celle-là oui probablement parce que ça
va lui donner une occasion de plus et il
n'en a pas manqué ces derniers mois
depuis les élections législatives de de
juin de l'année dernière de se
respectabiliser de s'institutionnaliser
encore plus que ce n'était le cas
jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui après pour
répondre à votre à une autre question
est-ce que ça va profiter au LR j'en
suis pas persuadé non plus parce que on
voit bien le choix tactique vous en avez
parlé tous les deux mais certes ce parti
est tiraillé entre une sorte de soutien
critique et une opposition frontale on
quand même que depuis quelques jours
même depuis quelques semaines on est
beaucoup plus dans dans la radicalité
contre contre le gouvernement et contre
le président de la République pourquoi
parce que les LR ont enfin compris que
jouer le le jeu de le rôle de parti d'A
pointint et forcément vous employez le
terme mortifè mais c'est exactement ça
enfin l'histoire politique récente est
truffé de de de forces stratégiqu qui
qui pouvait emporter ou créer une
majorité absolue mais qui en s'allant
avec le bloc majoritaire en tout cas le
bloc le plus important finisse par
disparaître et là on le voit bien oui le
risque serait de se oudre dans une
majorité présidentielle recomposée avec
àair à l'intérieur c'est mais vous avez
raison mais d'un autre côté ils sont
obligés de taper du point sur la table
parce que c'est s tre le moment LR ce
projet de loi sur l'immigration si on ne
parle pas delr au moment où on cherche
une loi sur l'immigration mais quand
est-ce qu'on va parler DLR d'autant plus
que ce profile évidemment et vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure les prochaines
élections européennes donc quelque part
ils sont un petit peu prisonniers de
cette stratégie de la Chae vide d'une
opposition de plus en plus frontal avec
toutes les conséquences que ça peut
avoir sur une partie de leur électoratin
l'électorat de LR ou en tout cas ce
qu'il en reste reste favorable à une
modification de la loi sur l'immigration
et si la droite devait l'empêcher devait
empêcher ce vote quelque part une partie
de cet électorat serait lu lui en
vouloir après oui le le lui rappeler euh
Franck Morel est-ce que c'est aussi le
signe cette sensation de d'un d'un parti
balloté ou sans cap d'un manque j'allais
dire d'une absence c'est le terme éopor
mais d'un manque de travail idéologique
je me souviens que au moment des
première rencontre précisément de de
Saint-Denis euh un certain nombre d'écho
euh qui s'était manifesté sur la manière
dont cette rencontre s'était déroulé
avait mentionné précisément le fait que
Jordan Bardella avait été identifié
comme ayant préparé avec beaucoup de
sérieux euh beaucoup d'approfondissement
justement cette réunionl et ça c'est su
et ça c'est su et c'était fait sans
doute pour que ça se sache et que ça se
dise dans la stratégie de notabilisation
effectivement que que vous évoqueiez et
donc effectivement faire le choix de ne
pas aller à ces secondes rencontres
c'est faire le choix après que un
travail a pu être mené au Sénat et ça a
été dit tout à l'heure par le sénateur
d'bress effectivement assez approfondi
avec un certain nombre de de de
dispositions qui ont été modifiées qui
vont dans le sens de LR c'est faire le
choix de passer à une autre séquence
pour passer d'une certaine manière ça
par pertes et profits et ne pas aller
sur un terrain qui serait le terrain
justement de la valorisation d'un
travail de fond pour aller sur un
terrain d'identification plus binaire
sur le fait de de mettre en avant de ne
pas aller de ne pas aller à Saint-Denis
et donc vous avez raison ça peut pointer
une une forme de de difficulté à exister
par le fond à exister en réalité par le
fait de alors même que LR effectivement
a mis sur la table un certain nombre de
propositions assez poussé assez détaillé
sur les modifications constitutionnelles
par exemple mais on a le sentiment que
n'arrive pas à le valoriser et ne se
sent pas mê que la stratégie va
peut-être contradiction avec le travail
sur les idées c'est je vais même plus
loin et je vais même plus loin et que LR
ne s ne se sent peut-être pas
suffisamment sûr de soi pour être
capable de le valoriser dans un saint
numéro 2 et ça c'est c'est c'est très
symptomatique sauf que Bruno cotress le
la ligne idéologique de LR est-ce
qu'elle est si facile à définir parce en
fonction des thématiques le régalien
l'économique le social on va on va
peut-être être plus ou moins proche du
rassemblement national ou de ou de
renaissance d'une certaine façon ouais
là c'est vraiment le cœur du suj au fond
il y a à la fois cette dimension de
travail intellectuel normalement c'est
la vocation d'une machine politique et
le parti politique de d'être un
pourvoyeur d'idées de programme de
thèmees de réflexion de sortir des
documents qui font réfléchir les
adhérents et c'est vrai que on a du mal
pour le moment à voir tout ça à venir du
côté des républicains mais il y a ce
problème fondamental dont vous parlez
notre vie politique elle est depuis
plusieurs décennies TR qu décennies dans
un espace en deux dimensions et les
républicain mais ça vaut aussi pour les
socialistes sont écartelés par ces deux
dimensions ils n'ont pas la cohérence
programmatique que peuvent avoir les
extrême ils sont écartelés leurs
électeurs sur les questions régaliennes
sont aujourd'hui plus proches de ceux du
rassemblement national que ceux de
renaissance ils ne sont pas
intermédiaires entre les deux sur les
questions régaliennes la loi l'ordre la
sécurité l'immigration par contre par
contre sur les questions économiques qui
sont plus proches des sympathisants des
du parti présidentiel que ceux du
rassemblement national oui donc la
synthèse elle est compliquire syn
trs la synthèse est très compliquée ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas de leur fitte
voilà c'est ils sont dans un
environnement qui est de ce point de
vuel qui a gagné en complexité au cours
des 30 40 dernières années ils sont pas
les seuls en Europe la la leur famille
politique au plan européen connaît les
mêmes incertitude stratégique on observe
tous au niveau européen qu'au niveau de
leur groupe PPE bah c'est pas exactement
le PPE d' une quinzaine ou une vingtaine
d'années sur les questions climatiques
qui sont en train de d'être un peu plus
sur l'idée que on en a assez parlé donc
voilà on voit l'ensemble de la famille
du centre droit qui est dans cette
situation avec un monde globalisé ouvert
où les question d'immigration de
frontières viennent un peu les chercher
sur des thématiques sur lesquelles ils
ont toujours été très forts mais sur
l'économie ils sont très favorables à un
monde ouvert de de compétition mais en
même temps fermé qui ressemble à ce
quiemmanuel Macron
je sais pasil y Arve DEP com comment
expliquer qu'on est qu'on est qu'on est
ouvert à l'extérieur sur l'économie mais
qu'on l' pas sur d'autres dimension
c'est très compliqué voilà ils sont ils
sont dans une situation qui n'est qui
n'est que le produit d'évolution qui qui
leur échappe donc c'est c'est très
difficile et ils n'ont pas trouvé le le
le leader qui arrive à faire la synthèse
pas
d'incarnation c'est une question de
leadership
aussi depuis la présidentielle de 2022
c'està-dire que il y a eu cette primaire
il y a eu le score de Valérie PCR en
2022 ériic cioti qui est à la tête du
parti mais un parti qui a autant la
culture du chef et qui aujourd'hui
manque de de direction et de leadership
ça s'en ressent évidemment dans dans les
prises de position et dans les divisions
internes évidemment à ça on y reviendra
en détail tout à l'heure on parlera
ensemble de de de Laurent vquier entre
autres mais je voudrais qu'on se
concentre sur ce ce bras de fer qui est
en train de se dessiner entre député et
sénateur LR je propose à à Jonathan
Dupri de nous rejoindre donc sur ce
texte immigration bonsoir Jonathan on
aurait pu imaginer un bras de fer LR
gouvernement sauf que c'est un bras
defire interne oui absolument et les
deux groupes parlementaires donc du même
camp ils sont encore très loin
d'accorder leur violence sur ce texte
immigration qui vient d'être voté au
Sénat c'est un texte dont tout le monde
s'accorde ici y compris les sénateurs
aler eux-mêmes à dire qu'il est allé
sensiblement plus loin à très à droite
en tout cas il est allé beaucoup plus
loin que la version gouvernementale les
sénateurs ils ont poussé le texte
vraiment sur sa droite on va voir les
mesures principales emblématiques qui
sont sorties de de cette de cet examen
alors il y a la suppression de l'aide
médicale d'État devenu aide médicale
d'urgence la limitation du regroupement
familial ou encore l'instauration de
quotas sur l'immigration économique en
ressort en tout cas selon le président
de la commission des Lois du Sénat une
version dite équilibrée en tout cas
François Noël buffet s'en félicite
écoutez-le le texte qui sort du Sénat à
l'origine c'est 24 articles ou 26
articles on ressort avec un peu plus de
90 articles donc on a complètement
remolé les choses le gouvernement a en
grande partie donné des avis favorables
quelques sagesse mais donc de ce fait
partage en toutous les cas par la voix
de son ministre le texte du Sénat
j'imagine bien que tout ça a été un peu
préparé en tous les cas je le souhaite
pour l'arrivée du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale alors là pour le son de cloche
côté sénateur LR alors si on se tourne
vers les bands de l'Assemblée nationale
Jonathan au contraire ils disent quoi
ils disent que ce texte va pas assez
loin ouais ça va pas assez loin c'est
surtout ericti qui bloc à noté une
petite info Eric cotti n'est jamais venu
au Sénat au groupe politique pendant la
préparation les négociations autour de
de l'examen du texte immigration ce qui
peut-être en dit en dit long sur sur sa
position en tout cas il est lui partisan
d'une ligne très très dure he en clair
il ne veut pas ouvrir la porte à une
quelconque régularisation de s papiers
dans ce texte or sur ce point les LR au
Sénat je vais essayer d'être très
pédagog et ben ils ont pas eu d'autre
choix que de faire un compromis pour
satisfaire ici leurs alliés centristes
de la majorité sénatoriale qui qui eux
étaient favorable à certaines mesures
des alliés sans qui LR ne pourrait
jamais avoir la majorité pour faire
voter son texte la droite donc a
supprimé ce fameux article 3 dont on a
beaucoup parlé remplacé par le 4 vous
allez voir qui laisse à la discrétion
des préfets la régularisation au cas par
cas des travailleurs des métiers dit en
tension ce texte n'inversera pas les
grandes tendances à singler Eric cioti
dans le Figaro et qui ajoute le Sénat a
fait un bon travail pour améliorer le le
texte mais je dis très clairement
l'article 4 bis qui s'est substitué à
l'article 3 qui introduisait dans la loi
le principe de régulation me gêne et
certains tapent encore plus fort comme
le député du lotte Aurélien Pradier je
je propose de l'écouter je ne parlerai
pas de victoire je parlerai de ce que
c'est une reculade il se trouve que je
ne suis pas sénateur je suis député et
je pense que la position que je porte
d'intransigence sur le sujet de
l'immigration c'est une position que
beaucoup de députés les républiains vont
porter dans les jours qui viennent
évidemment cette sortie d'Oren Pradier a
fait réagir plusieurs sénateurs LR ouais
ça a pas fait plaisir ici au Sénat a
commencé par le patron du groupe LR
Bruno rotillot qui s'est étranglé he de
de ses propos pour lui au contraire le
le texte et bien il contient tous les
marqueurs de la droite voire peut-être
même plus écoutez-le hier il réagissait
au micro de Quentin calma come on dit
chez moi vaut mieux entendre de ça que
d'être sourd voilà il faut qu'il
travaille qu'il le lise jamais de
mémoire de députés ou de sénateur LR
nous n'avions été la droite aussi ferme
voilà je je vois des sourires sur le
plateau le feuilleton est loin d'être
terminé à droite he d'autant qu' hier il
y a un nouvel acteur qui est rentré un
peu dans le dans le jeu le président de
la région au Vergne ronalp Laurent
vquier candidat putatif à l'élection
présidentielle on verra il est entré
dans la mêlée il s'est invité à la
réunion des 62 députés LR à l'Assemblée
nationale et il s'est voulu rassembleur
hein ça je je cite des propos de de
politico le Sénat a fait passer un
tournant clair à ce texte a-t-il dit en
défendant plus ou moins le travail des
sénateurs il a reconnu en tout cas un
projet de loi certes perfectible mais il
dit il n'y a pas pas une feuille de
papier à cigarette entre député et
sénateur LR bon on verra si ça suffit à
rabiboucher tout le monde merci beaucoup
Jonathan Bruno cotè est-ce que on l' un
peu évoqué mais je voudrais bien vous
entendre dans le détail là-dessus on est
en train de revivre le scénario des
retraites moi je je lis j'entends
beaucoup ça c'est clairement ce qui ce
qui se profile à l'horizon là avec on
s'en souvient des députés LR qui
finalement ne ne votent pas le texte qui
avait été appment négocié ici au C voilà
ça devient un jeu très très compliqué
parce qu'en fait c'est vrai que si du
côté de l'Assemblée nationale on dit ça
va pas assez loin ben la grande question
évidemment que ça pose tout de suite
c'est où est la majorité pour voter ce
texte euh donc il y a peut-être aussi
une dimension stratégique est-ce qu'il
s'agit aussi d'amener le le gouvernant
de le pousser dans ses retranchements
encore une fois de lui faire pression
parce que le ministre s'est très engagé
sur l'idée pas de 493 je ne veux pas de
493 il s'est montré très confiant à
l'issue du vote du du Sénat il avait
l'air extrêmement content du travail
fait par le Sénat il a eu des mots assez
élogieux et il a redit à ce moment-là
qu'il voulait pas être 493 donc on voit
qu'il y a une dimension aussi une autre
dimension stratégique si finalement le
gouvernement était obligé de dégainer le
le 493
euh c'est vrai que globalement ça
montrera encore une fois que le
gouvernement n'a pas de n'a pas de
majorité donc on revient effectivement
vers un peu ce ce scénario avec toujours
ce problème un gouvernement qui n'a pas
de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale Stéphane zsek com comment
l'opinion alors on va plutôt parler des
sympathisants LR pas seulement les
militants évidemment mais comment
l'opinion a vécu cet épisode des
retraites très mal très mal al d'abord
les les gens qui se réclament toujours
deslr il y en a plus beaucoup voilà ils
sont moins nombreux qu'auparavant
François Fillon fait 20 % Valérie PCR en
fait moins de 5 tout le monde connaiss
ces
chiffresis je P on va dire l'opinion des
gens de droite qui trouvent encore un
peu d'espace entre le bloc présidentiel
et et la droite radicale et est
profondément désorienté enfin tout ce
qu'on a vu là dans votre reportage sur
la succession des prises de parole
montre que en fait les aler sont
totalement inaudible on ne sait pas qui
est le chef on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
veulent d'ailleurs on comprend qu'ils ne
savent pas inudible parce qu'il y a trop
de son de cloche différents c'est ça
parce qu'il y a trop de son de cloche
différents d'une part et d'autre part
parce que parce que visiblement si vous
êtes un électeur LR si vous êtes en
général parce que c'est un peu ça la
sociologie de cet électorat un peu
vieillissant vous voulez quoi vous
voulez que l'Assemblée nationale
fonctionne que le Parlement fonctionne
vous voulez que des majorités se
dégagent or les LR font tout en ce
moment en tout cas en surenchérissant
sur la sur le projet de loi immigration
pour que aucune majorité ne se dégage
c'est le premier point et d'autre part
comment expliquer comment apparaître
crédible et j'ai envie de dire sérieux
auprès de son propre électorat alors que
vous êtes issu alors que vous
représentez un des principaux partis de
gouvernement de ces 50 dernières années
comment faites-vous pour convaincre ce
qu'il vous reste de l'électorat que ça
vaut ça vaut le coup de voter pour vous
c'est ça ils sont vraiment pris là dans
un piège c'est très compliqué il y a eu
les frondeurs lors de la réforme des
retraites ça a laissé des traces
absolument dévastatrices au sein de
l'opinion de droite parce que personne
n'a compris c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose parce que mais c'est j'ai
c'est pire en fait ce n'est pas juste un
tiers des députés qui s'opposent à la
direction du parti là c'est carrément en
bloc les sénateurs LR qui s'opposent ENF
qui ne sont pas du même avis que les
députés ça donne l'impression en fait
d'une cacophonie et d'un parti qui est
totalement perdu vous parliez tout à
l'heure de évidemment de l'Incarnation
personnelle oui il y a plus ja il y a
plus de Nicolas Sarkozi que faire et je
le répète on se profile les élections
européennes pour l'instant en tout cas
on s'oriente
vers trop par math nous en parlera dans
dans un instant et effectivement
beaucoup de chos à dire sur la
perspective des élections européennes je
je livre et ça va dans le sens de ce que
vous venez de nous dire cette dernière
information sondage odoxa pour évaluer
l'impact dans l'opinion du refus de
notamment des LR mais aussi du Parti
socialiste et de LFI de se rendre demain
aux rencontres de Saint-Denis 51 % des
Français trouvent que c'est une erreur
de refuser de de de se rendre à ces
rencontres et alors là où ça devient
intéressant pour notre débat c'est que
si on va un peu plus finement regarder
ce qu'on pensent les sympathisants LR on
est à 59 % euh Franck Morel moi j'ai
j'ai ce sentiment et on en vient au
culte du chef on sait plus est-ce que je
sais pas si je vais arriver à compter
les chapelles quoi au sein au sein de de
LR entre le Sénat le parti et les auto
entrepreneurs de de de de l'Assemblée
vous avez employé le terme
d'auto-entrepreneur il a déjà été
utilisé effectivement pour caractériser
une forme de de balcanisation de
chapellisation hein entre guillemets de
de très comment dire nombreuse hein au
sein de de l'Assemblée nationale moi je
voudrais revenir effectivement pour
répondre à votre question aussi sur cet
épisode de du vote au Sénat et puis des
positions divergentes à l'Assemblée au
sein de LR sur la le projet de loi
immigration c'est vrai que
traditionnellement indépendamment du
contexte que l'on connaît aujourd'hui on
a toujours un sénat qui est plus
constructif entre guillemets qui est
plus dans la recherche du compromis qui
est plus feutré où les débats sont moins
passionnels et cetera et où à
l'Assemblée en revanche on revient sur
des débats plus tranchés plus politisés
au sens clivant du terme hein donc ça
c'est quelque chose de toute manière que
l'on rencontre et de manière assez
régulière et il n'est pas surprenant
qu'il puisse y avoir une part de cette
dimension là dans le cadre de l'examen
du projet de loi immigration sauf que on
voit que vient se surajouter à ça une
forme de rivalité entre Bruno rotaillo
d'un côté et Eric cotti de l'autre et là
on n'est pas uniquement dans le côté sén
versu sassemblée on est aussi sur des
logiques un peu personnelles historiques
vient s'ajouter aussi certes la volonté
de Gérard Larché de faire en sorte que
le Sénat imprime sa patte existe et ça
s'est vu d'ailleurs vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure à travers le fait que
Gérard Larcher sera présent à
Saint-Denis et donc on voit bien que
bien au-delà d'un simple processus assez
habituel assez classique de discussion
plus apaisé au Sénat que par rapport à
l'Assemblée nationale on est exacerbe
encore plus ces différences à travers
une difficulté en réalité euh à jouer
simplement de ça pour avoir en fait une
véritable stratégie consistant parce que
ça ça aurait pu être le cas consistant à
dire on va jouer la carte Séna pour
faire retomber le soufflet pour apaiser
un peu et puis on remontera un peu
derrière la la mayonnaise hein on
remontera un peu la tension derrière à
l'Assemblée nationale pour obtenir un
peu des choses des choses en plus ça
aurait pu être une stratégie mais on a
pas l'impression que c'est une stratégie
consciente en réalité c'est quelque
chose d'assez subi du fait de cette
parcellisation alors la la la question
du du leader du du chef alors la
présidentielle c'est dans 3 ans et demi
donc bon que valulent les sondages à
aussi loin d'unun d'un scrutin je vais
pas vous poser cette question là c'est
pas le thème de notre débat vous me
remerciez mais ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que à l'instanté le candidat putatif
voquier ne décolle pas on regardz ce ce
sondage sais pas vous c'est hiob
fiduciale qui date du 31 octobre dernier
on a une Marine Le Pen à 31 % Édouard
Philippe 26 % Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
Laurent vquier il faut descendre dans la
liste à 5 %. Bruno cotress est-ce qu'on
surestime l'influence de Laurent vquier
sur le parti LR d'près vous elle est
elle est grande quand même ça reste
quand même une de leurs principales
figures dans la perspective d'élection
présidentielle il continue de de de
disposer je pense une image quand même
de quelqu'un qui a la la stature d'une
personnalité politique nationale il
s'est imposé à lui-même une cure euh à
la fois d'abstinence médiatique il a
envoyé des messages qu'il était dans une
phase de réflexion il a publié une
longue interview il y a quelques mois
quelques semaines dans le journal Le
Point qui était dans le message était de
dire j'ai j'ai j'ai réfléchi à mes
erreurs j'ai progressé en réflexion mais
maintenant quand même le cap sur un
terme de points fondamentaux de de
l'envoquer et effectivement Eric cotti a
clairement dit qu'il était son candidat
lorsqu'il a pris la présidence du du
parti donc tout le monde un peu attend
ce que va faire Laurent voquier à quel
moment il affirmerait une stratégie
vis-à-vis de l'élection présidentielle
dans un univers LR qui est un qui est un
univers avec beaucoup d'incertitude de
ce de ce point de vue-là avec des
ambitions personnelles qui commencent à
s'exprimer autour de leur envoquier qui
vont le pousser à agir for forcément
forcément il va être poussé à ce alors
la la la stratégie qu'il a qu'il a
adopté c'est cette stratégie je pense de
susciter un peu le désir de leenvoquer à
à l'in illeurs mais c'est vrai que ça ne
décolle pas il y a d'ailleurs aucun pour
lequel ça décolle quand certains
sondages ont été fait qui tèent des
hypothèses alternative à Laurent voquier
qu'il s'agisse de Xavier Bertrand qu'il
s'agisse de David Lisnard ça ne décolle
absolument pas donc ils sont dans une
situation qui est pour le moment une
situation de de de de grande difficulté
par rapport à ça Stéphan zums votre avis
là-dessus parce que le le la présence de
Laurent vquier dont nous parlait
Jonathan du prièz à cette réunion des
députés elle est en fait c'était la
première fois qu'il venait de depuis les
élections législatives est-ce que c'est
le signe d'un changement de stratégie je
pense que on lui a beaucoup reproché y
compris au sein de son propre parti une
certaine absence notamment au moment de
la réforme de retraite quand il a
vraiment fallu trancher je reviens à
l'épisode de cette petite vingtaine de
de députés qui se sont quand même qui
ont qui ont front évidemment le Paris de
Laurent voquier c'est de se dire que le
macronisme n'aura été qu'une parenthèse
en 2027 ce sera la fin c'est en tout cas
ce qu'il P enfin ce qu'il espère la fin
de cette expérience et qu'on en
reviendra à un clivage classique
classique gauche c'est pas le seul à
faire ce Paris d'ailleurs c'est pas le
seul et une sorte de bipolarisation
comme on a vu entre un parti centre
gauche et un parti centre- droit oui
mais aujourd'hui y compris quand on
interroge les électeurs de droite et les
sympathisants LR c'est qui aujourd'hui
les personnalités les mieux perçu les
plus dont on approuve le plus l'action
c'est Édouard Philippe ça peut être
Gérald dermanin sur certains points ça
peut être Bruno Le Maire bien plus que
Xavier Bertrand ou Laurent vquier c'est
ça le problème donc l'enjeu pour lui ce
sera de réussir à recréer un espace
entre entre Renaissance entre le
successeur celui qui sera désigné comme
candidat en tout cas pour succéder à
Emmanuel Macron et R remblement national
on en est bien loin vous citiez tout à
l'heure un sondage présidentiel certes
on en est encore loin mais on se
rapproche à grand pas de l'élection
européenne et aujourd'hui les mesures
qui sont faites sont très très
désevantes et très inquiétantes pour
pour les alr on a publié nous ce weekend
dans la tribune une enquête qui mettait
la liste si elle été conduite par
François Xavier bami à 6 % ce que je
veux dire c'est que même si les choses
vont encore évoluer dans les mois qui
viennent l'hypothèse que les LR ne
tiennent pas la BAR n'atteignent pas la
barre fatitique des 5 % elle n'est pas
baroque comment ensuite mettre sur
orbite ouais un candidat prés qu'il
qu'il que sa liste fasse 5 6 7 ou 8 %
comment être crédible derrière d'autant
plus que ce sera la surenchère à droite
y compris au sein du du camp macronien
et que ce sera encore plus compliqué en
cas de contreperformance aux élections
européennes d'exister après ouais 9 juin
je rappelle que c'est la date de ce
scrutin européen c'est en moins de 7
mois mathil il y a pas mal d'inquiétude
au sein de cette droite LR à propos de
cette échéance et bien oui Thomas
puisque même si la campagne n'a pas
encore débuté on vient de le dire les
sondages sont vraiment
très peu flatteur pour le parti
d'ericioti avec un scénario noir que
tous les responsables ont en tête à
droite celui d'être relégué en 6e voire
en 7e position derrière notamment la
liste reconquête menée par Marion
maréchal et cette candidature de la nièe
de Marine Le Pen elle complique
d'ailleurs l'équation pour LR puisque
Marion maréchal incarne une ligne
identitaire et conservatrice pas très
éloigné finalement de celle que porte
l'eurodéputé François Xavier bami qui n
pas encore déclaré mais qui est
fortement pressenti pour mener cette
liste LR comme en 2019 donc c'est un
espace politique pour la droite
républicaine qui se retrouve
considérablement réduit alors que au
niveau européen la droite européenne le
PPE pourrait sortir gagnante de ce
scrutin et les républicains risquent de
se retrouver à la traain par rapport à
leurs alliés mais aussi au niveau
national avec quel conséquen pour
l'avenir de ce parti alors Thomas on a
annoncé main de fois le c'est la mort
des républicains mais cette fois il faut
reconnaître qu'avec un score en juin qui
serait peu ou prou celui de Valérie pcrè
autour de de 5 % on l'a dit les
européennes pourraient sonner le glas de
la formation politique historique de la
droite he de Jacques Chirac alors voici
ce qu'on entend dans les couloirs du
parti on ne va pas se raconter
d'histoire si on fait moins de 5 % on se
posera la question de présenter un
candidat en 2027 Laurent vquier qui rêve
de l'Élysée va donc regarder de très
près cette élection mais aussi la
majorité qui verrait au contraire dans
cette chute de LR l'opportunité de
concrétiser ce projet de coalition hein
qui flotte quand même on en entend
beaucoup parler depuis le début du
kquena et et qui est notamment défendu
par Nicolas Sarkozi d'autant que du côté
de ce que l'on appelle le bloc central
ceux qui se positionnent pour la
présidentielle viennent plutôt de la
droite Édouard Philippe Gérald armanin
Bruno Le Maire sont tous issus des
républicains effectivement on l' évoqué
merci beaucoup mathil donc il y a deux
questions que vous abordez là il y a la
la probabilité d'un nouveau fiasco
électoral et puis la capacité de LIR à y
survivre on va aborder ces deux
questions ensemble peut-être Bruno cotrè
pour commencer alors 7 mois c'est c'est
long en politique mais quand même
l'hypothèse d'une liste LR sous les 5 %
c'est plausible aujourd'hui justement
avec la présence de reconte si on prend
au sérieux les intention de vote publi
aujourd'hui et qu'on leur qu'on les
prend au sérieux c'estàdire on voit en
calcul les fameuses marges d'erreur on
voit que c'est possible effectivement
alors là c'est la catastrophe c'est le
cataclysme total si c'était le cas pour
les républicains non seulement ça veut
dire pas de députés européens ça
inscrirait au fond le score de Valérie
pcrez dans quelque chose qui n'était pas
le problème pcrz ça voudrait dire que le
problème est bien ailleurs et là pour
l'organisation politique c'est terrible
parce que ça oblige à se poser les
questions les plus fondamentales on peut
dire que l'accident industriel de
Valérie pcrè on dit la campagne n'a pas
pris voilà et cetera mais là là si ça se
reproduit déjà rappelons-nous qu'aux
précédentes européennes lorsque la liste
François Xavier bami avait fait 8 % on
peut voir les chiffres d'ailleurs le
rassemblement national en tête je
rappelle les chiffres je vous laisse
conclure après 2331 lrem 2241 et
effectivement pardon LR à 848 voilà mais
peut-être peut-être qu'aujourd'hui ils
achèteraient tout de suite 848 donc donc
voilà on voit on voit quelque chose une
élection et puis et puis les élections
européennes effectivement ça vient
d'être rappelé c'est une élection la
famille politique des républicains elle
compte toujours quand même beaucoup il y
a de gros partis en Europe qui sont
associés au Républicain à l'intérieur de
ce groupe de la famille du du du PPE
donc pour eux ça serait en plus une
humiliation européenne très importante
et effectivement avec des effets en en
chaîne sans doute très important on a
dit tout à l'heure il y a une logique de
balcanisation peut-être que cette
logique de balcanisation elle serait
accentuée elle serait
appuyéeil donc ça veut dire que certains
IR iraient plutôt côté RN d'autres
plutôt côté majorité présou la tentation
de créer un nouveau mouvement
politique certains ont créé déjà des on
va dire des structures politiques
parallèles au partis donc peut-être
l'idée de dire bon ben là vraiment il
faut vraiment envoyer le faire part de
décès des républicains et afficher plus
clairement euh des hypothèses
alternatives y compris des hypothèses
d'organisation alternative euh Franck
Morel est la deuxème partie de la
question euh donc là on a évoqué la
probabilité de ce nouveau fiasco mais
c'est est-ce que LR peut y survivre ben
je crois que ce qui est intéressant
c'est de se plonger un petit peu dans
l'histoire et de regarder ce qui s'est
passé après plusieurs scrutins européens
parce que vous l'avez dit les
européennes c'est quand même un scrutin
très particulier qui très souvent met
dans une position plus aisée des partis
qui se présentent comme étant un peu
hors système ou ou hors sentier battu on
va dire je vais vous donner trois
exemples euh scrutin de
1994 c'est le scrutin qui a signé l'acte
de décès des ambitions présidentielles
de Michel Rocard Michel Rocard à
l'époque était tête de liste du Parti
socialiste Bernard tapi menait une liste
radicale et avait réussi à obtenir un
score assez conséquent euh doncun disait
un peu téléguidé par le président
mitéran à l'époque et en tout cas qui a
abouti à à la fin définitive des
ambitions présidentielles de Michel
Rocard 2uxème exemple
1999 Nicolas Sarkozi remplace en
catastrophe Philippe segin comme tête de
liste euh de la droite modérée à
l'époque et Charles pascoy et Philippe
dev Villier mènent une liste qui arrive
devant la liste officielle de la droite
modérée à l'époque ça a généré une
traversée du désert qui a duré quelques
années de Nicolas Sarkozi trisème
exemple ça a été projeté il y a quelques
minutes le score de LR en en 2000 lors
des dernières élections en 2019 voilà
lors des dernières élections européennes
ça a produit quand même la démission de
leur envoqué euh du de la tête de la
tête des républicains et donc les
européennes c'est un scrutin qui est
toujours compliqué pour les partis dit
de gouvernement ou les partis qui qui
sont perçu comme étant assez classique
on va dire dans des couloirs de nage
assez classiques et qui profitent
beaucoup aux extrêmes d'un côté au
parties hors système de l'autre et qui
peuvent produire effectivement des
formes de recomposition ou de de de de
de cataclysme d'une certaine manière en
matière politique est-ce que ce que vous
décrivez je vous pose la question à vous
Stéphan ça n'incite pas les les poids
lourds alors je je je dis ça euh voilà
en étant très respectueux évidemment de
François Xavier benénami mais est-ce que
ça n'incite pas les poours à ne pas y
aller vous voyez ce que je veux dire on
est en train de parler de l'incarnation
du manque d'incarnation de d'un parti où
un chef doit sa'vooir Cheffer et qui et
qui n'en fait pas ressortir aujourd'hui
voilà si c'est pour prendre autant de
coup personne va y aller quoi je suis
pas sûr que quelqu'un aurait aujourd'hui
au sein deslr le même courage qu'avait
eu Nicolas Sarkozi à l'époque par malgré
tout c'était très courageux on peut
penser ce qu'on veut de Nicolas Sarkozi
mais ce qu'il avait fait il savait qu'il
allait au caspip he quelque part et
malgré tout c'était aussi un moyen pour
lui de de de s'affirmer maintenant sur
la pérénité du DLR je veux pas être
provocateur mais on parle de de la fin
de la marque l'éventuelle fin de la
marque LR ou l'éventuelle fin de la
droite de gouvernement parce que quelque
part l'avenir de DLR c'est peut-être ça
s'inscrit peut-être dans ce que
deviendra la macronie en cas de
réélection en cas d'élection du candidat
macroniste aux prochaines à la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que la
droite de gouvernement elle existe elle
est au pouvoir en fait oui aujourd'hui
quand on voit on est plus du tout dans
le schéma de de 2017 mais de 2022 et ce
qui est on parle de ce sifonage
progressif et de et finalement de de de
de cette de ce potentiel électoral
réduit à pot de chagrin pour les LR mais
ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est quand
même frappant c'est que dans le contexte
actuel d'impopularité du président de la
République et de la majorité
présidentielle il y a personne qui
revient au berkaille ces gens-là alors
soit part ailleurs soit part vers le RN
il y en a pas beaucoup vers l'abstention
en tout cas tout le monde est très
critique y compris au sein de cet
électorat démocrate chrétien ou libéral
à l'égard du gouvernement mais ça ne
profite en rien à aucun moment r jamais
et ça c'est un vrai problème il y a un
problème aussi de marque sur le l'avenir
politique on peut d'ailleurs avoir la
même réflexion sur le Parti socialiste
Bruno cotteres sont des partis qui
survivent en partie grâce à à leur maire
ou à leur président de région mais
est-ce que ça suffit pour tenir
éternellement vous voyez ce que je veux
dire non non ça suffit pas c'est pas
inscrit dans le marbre la fameuse prime
au sortant a une durée de péremption on
ne peut pas tenir 30 ans sur la prime au
sortant il y a de temps en temps des
élus locaux qui arrivent à survivre sur
plusieurs élections municipales mais ça
une dur de vie assez limité quand un
mère a déjà fait d'origine s'affaiblit à
un moment où ça voà quand un mère a déjà
fait deux mandats la troisème élection
est souvent un peu compliquée donc ça a
pas une durée de vie éternelle et ils ne
peuvent pas uniquement tout mettre sur
l'idée que ils ont le temps de voir
venir parce qu'ils ont leurs bastions
municipaux régionaux départementaux
éventuellement donc il faut à un moment
donné pour que tout ça se maintienne à
Flo qui effectivement de temps en temps
une grande incarnation et quelque chose
qui dit que ça existe encore dans
l'opinion fortement avec l'élection
présidentielle c'est absolument
fondamental et rappelons quand même que
ça fait maintenant plusieurs élections
présidentiel de rendez-vous manqués pour
la droite 2012 2017 2022 est-ce qu'ils
peuvent se permettre 2027 un gros crash
et la situation paradoxale DLR c'est
qu'en même temps que ces questions se se
posent ils ont en même temps un peu une
balle de match en main pour l'élection
de 2027 c'estàdire que on voit
bien je parle sous le contrôle d'un
sondeur que s'il y avait un candid and
de centre droit plus un candidat de
centre droit
macroniste peut-être que c'est
problématique pour les deux oui
effectivement alors je vais vous donner
la parole tout de suite franc Maren mais
un dernier un dernier élément dans dans
dans ce débat sur la question de la
bascule de LR vers l'extrême droite
voici une critique exprimé par la
sénatrice socialiste Mariepierre de la
gontere c'était lors des débats sur le
texte
immigration votre texte mesdames et
messieurs de la majorité sénatoriale
reprend consciencieusement en s'alignant
avec les propositions du Front National
et de Marine Le Pen sur chacun des
thèmes évoqués lors de l'examen de ce
projet de loi votre aile la plus dure a
emporté le groupe LR nous vivons
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues un
moment de clarification de la droite
française ce texte au parcours chaotique
s'achève dans un naufrage pour la droite
et une rupture avec notre modèle
républicain mais aussi avec l'héritage
du gaulisme et l'ambition de cohésion
que défendait Jacques Chirac alors plus
que de la dérive ver extrêm mais ça peut
se rejoindre c'est c'est l'héritage du
gaulisme qui incarne cet héritage
aujourd'hui Franck Morel al je vous trs
une percheelle est trop joli est-ce que
c Édouard Philippe avec qui vous avez
travaillé pendant des années à matinon
je suis pas très objectif pour répondre
par c'est pour ça que je dis dans ma
question d'eddouard Philippe je vais
vous dire qu'effectivement je je trouve
dans Édouard Philippe un certain nombre
d'éléments de nature à permettre
d'incarner mais est-ce que ça veut
encore dire quelque chose l'héritage du
goisme alors que le général de Gaulle
est mort en 197 on est 6 ça r un certain
nombre de valeur l'attachement aux
institutions de la 5e République une le
rôle de la France il y a un certain
nombre de valeur et effectivement on
peut considérer que un certain nombre de
personnalités Édouard Philippe en fait
partie incarne cet héritage moi je
voudrais revenir quand même sur un point
qui est la question que vous évoqueiez
tout à l'heure sur le fait de dire qu'en
réalité la droite de gouvernement elle
est au pouvoir en ce moment vous avez
dans ce qu'avait théorisé René Raymond
la fameuse histoire des trois droites
vous savez avec la droite Orléan la
droite bonapartiste et la droite
légitimiste et à une époque la droite
modérée était capable de fédérer ces
trois droites et c'était justement une
force et notamment dans l'héritage du
gaulisme notamment vous aviez cette
fédération alors autour de la droite
plutôt bonapartiste mais en tout cas
vous aviez cette fédération des trois
droites qui faisait la force et
l'ancrage dans le temps de la capacité
de la droite à rester au pouvoir et
aujourd'hui forcé de constater que
a déjà ne coche pas la case s'agissant
de la droite orléaniste la droite
orléaniste n'est pas du tout àr elle est
plutôt du côté de la droite de
gouvernement a du mal par rapport par
exemple à Eric Zemour a incarné la
droite légitimiste il y a une partie de
la droite légitimiste plutôt
conservatrice plutôt croyante très très
catholique et cetera qui est plutôt chez
Eric Zemour et puis s'agissant de la
droite d'onapartiste elle va être un
petit peu HLR mais un petit peu aussi
effectivement dans la droite de
gouvernement actuel donc on a plus cette
fédération des trois droites qui faisait
la force de euh je dirais pendant
pendant un certain temps effectivement
de la droite de gouvernement merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat qui était passionnant je vous
dis à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat